gary what the hell are you doing
oh gosh well i dropped my wedding ring
down this great
then i was trying to get it out and i
dropped my keys down there too so
i can't leave but you know what the
light from the phone i can see it
i just oh
my gosh dang it my jitterbug
damn this takes me back mind if i stay
and watch
well not at all appreciate the company
oh
you know how i can get the ring out i
will use my driver's license
and my only credit card like chopsticks
gary no
nuts never fear i still have a passport
oh wait let me see your stamps
oh
wyatt why didn't you tell us you're
running for congress
well we didn't want to steal your
thunder steal my thunder
i'm sorry have you seen him wearing this
dress okay well in that case
uh yes i am
to ben to donna and joe to me i own my
own restaurant and several other
properties
it's always worth celebrating you're
here
who's gary oh i think that's supposed to
be me
ha-ha that's your new name gary gary
gary
gary is my real name yes after 30 years
my co-workers are finally going to call
me by my real name
oh boy i'm blessed here's a sich
i developed a dope new game show where i
ask couples scanless questions and they
have to guess what the other one
answered
i call this no you boo ah
that sounds like the newlywed game shut
up jerry it's not the newlywed game okay
it is totally the newlywed game but big
deal
everyone steals my favorite movie is
love don't cost a thing with nick cannon
which is based on camp bomby love
which is based on korean vs kramer or
something which i think was shakespeare
don't know don't care and what exactly
do you plan on doing with this game show
idea are you going to shove it up your
butt
no i'm going to test it out on you four
bing bongs and work out the kinks
then hire actual attractive people and
make a demo
what network is gonna buy a game show
from you there's a million networks out
there and they all need programming
spike g4 gsn fuse wow
boom zip kablam slurp slurp latin slurp
hd
i love slurp hd have you guys seen
ultimate battle smoothie
it's dope show oh my god
it's time to know y'all
i don't have the instrumental backing
track yet but it doesn't say boo right
there
hey everybody welcome to know ya boo i'm
your host
tom harford and with me as always is my
cgi puppy co-host
bobby the boo ruff ruff hey everybody
all right let's get to it first question
fellas which rock star would you lady
bang if she could bang
one rock star jerry
i believe i have heard donna talk about
prince
a lot what'd your boo say
all right i am having some serious deja
vu
how many times have you lost your
wedding ring
too many times to count and it causes
real trouble with gail
and any time i lose my ring she turns
into a real grumpy goose
is that so oh yeah she'll say you know
gary you'd lose your head if it wasn't
screwed on tight
and then she makes me go for the fresh
oranges for the morning oj yeah
and she says hey mr forgetful
well i mean those words i mean they
rattle around here for hours that's why
i've got to be extra careful with this
replacement ring
because of my
ah loss gonna order us some dinner
hey it's tom haverford back here with no
yaboo let's move to the next question
where is your favorite place to smush ya
boo
donna back on my bins let's check in
with your boo
he said her mercedes
cherry and donna on fire how about the
new sushi place in eagleton
i'm allergic to sushi every time i eat
more than 80 sushis i barf
hey ann you been any swanky restaurants
lately what's the occasion it's december
it's a time we celebrate our most sacred
and special event jerry dinner
what the hell is jerry dinner every time
we laugh at something stupid jerry does
we put a dollar in this box at the end
of the year we take all the cash and
treat ourselves to a fancy dinner
this year we have hundred and sixteen
dollars
oh geez and that's 5 17.
5 18. you guys that's
so mean it's not mean if he doesn't know
about it
it's like talking about people behind
their backs everybody wins
no you should at least invite jerry to
the dinner
that's hilarious you should do stand-up
you're kidding you suck
but if you're serious i actually have
been thinking about it
hey april uh matlock called he wants his
cardigan back
boom i'm out who's matlock
in honor of jerry dinner let's each say
our
favorite jerry moment from the past year
yes mine was
the time he slipped on the cinnabon and
landed in a bunch of garbage
my favorite cherry moment was when he
ate a bowl of glue
oh my favorite jerry moment is when
you switched out his potato soup with
glue and he didn't know
you're so cute when you're bullying babe
you know what amber's right this is mean
we are going to pick up jerry what no
it's christmas time don't you want to
eat good people not really ever
hey if we're going that way can we stop
at our place real quick because i forgot
to put on deodorant
and a jacket and one of my socks plus i
got a poop but i can stop anywhere for
that
let us in and it's cold outside and i
can't wear mittens because they're
unflattering to my hands
sorry guys this is your penance you can
come in
if you do something nice for jerry hey i
already did something nice for jerry
i drove here to take him to jerry dinner
oh donna
you can come in okay
merry christmas
anyway at the time that you told us you
were mugged in the park
what were you reaching for in the river
a
river burrito for a burrito yes ma'am
that was not one of my fighter moments
oh it's getting late we need to bounce i
can give you a ride oh thank you donna
i'm probably gonna get an earful when i
get home tonight
gail might even call me the b word
bozo wow we are very different people
that is one motivated worker bee you
guys doing experiments on jerry
yes cool
donna what are you doing here so early i
come bearing gifts
first off i got to do the maintenance to
open up that grate this morning
so here's your rings keys credit cards
and i found some heart medicine i was on
it no that's mine that's fine oh my gosh
also i thought i'd bring over some fresh
oranges for you and gail
okay well that is just so kind donna
thank you
you're one of a kind gary and i just
want to thank you for taking me down
memory lane
you big b word buddy
you